rise and shine it's an espresso time
good morning relief nation it's even my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe in that amazing gift you have
inside to you that needs to be shared
with the world so let's start the day
off right together grab your cup of
coffee and sit on today's message
produce nice movies in your mind
over to you Sadhguru to create fear you
have to use excessive imagination to not
be in fear you don't have to do anything
really is happening because of the
excessive imagination things that have
not happened you're creating what may
happen in your mind happens in thousand
different formats and most probably it
never happens the things that you feared
take hundred things that you have feared
probably 99 of them never happened isn't
it yes so you're here your fear is
always about that which does not exist
you cannot fight all you cannot overcome
that which does not exist we can
overcome something with that exists you
cannot overcome that which does not
exist you just have to give up that
effort enjoy the fear after all it
you're making you like horror movies yes
I mean you're saying no but you you're
producing them just they're not making
money that's all fear means you're
producing horror movies in your mind
nobody else is willing to watch that's
bad for the producer but you're
producing them so you produce something
else produce a comedy a love story
suspense thriller try and see today just
sit down
produce a love story a suspense thriller
a comedy fire five minutes more
you make in your mind really start using
your mind differently it is gotten into
your pattern just got into your pattern
of just creating horror movies all the
time you have watched enough horror
movies the boring create something else
even it's not that if you produce these
movies those things will happen in your
life still they may not happen at least
you enjoy the movie in reality it may
not happen so what at least you enjoy
what's happening in your mind if you
cannot enjoy what's happening in the
world isn't it that matter privilege
every human being deserves isn't it so
even though the world is not kind to him
at least his own mind should be kind to
him should produce some nice movies I
think it's incredibly powerful to wake
up and imagine your day going great I
think that's a powerful thing to do in
the morning I think most people do that
I think most people wake up and they
just file other day and and if you're
like most people you probably hit the
snooze button in the morning you know
immediately you let yourself down right
you set this goal for yourself I'm gonna
wake up but this time and I'm gonna get
to work and get busy and make my life
for myself and the first thing you do is
slam that snooze button and say it's
okay that I didn't follow through with
my goals the very first thing you do
every every morning is not follow
through on something you said you're
gonna do like how do you imagine that
playing out the rest of your day you
think that's a quality routine to
success no like design your morning
routine with intent design your morning
routine that you're imagining a positive
possible outcome for today one of the
things that I do when I wake up
I have an alarm that is Birds these
birds chirping instead of a crazy brown
I'm like how I wake up is important I'm
gonna be charred and like being yelled
at as I wake up I wake up 10 minutes
before the sunrise comes up I go to the
bath when I pick up a copy of my book
and I read one page in the book and in
that page I get two ideas from genius
legendary game-changing entrepreneurs
that I think about and when you are
around but much more important than
reading an entire book cover-to-cover
like this is one page because the point
of it is to be around success
people to be around people who who are
thinking positive or thinking big who
are challenging conventions and
challenging and longs to break you out
of your fog I don't know about you but
in the morning I'm in a fog like you
know like this just you know if I had a
decent sleep I'm still kind of groggy in
the morning I don't wake up yes believe
right ahead
it doesn't happen in the morning right I
wake up and I'm tired but those are you
follow me on snapchat Instagram like you
may see my post one when I first wake up
and reading the book gives me the right
mindset when you're reading something
from Steve Jobs or Eric Thomas or
whoever it is people that you look up to
and respect and you see their
perspective and how they think and how
they see the world having that seep into
you when a daily basis changes you so I
read a page in the book you get to great
ideas I drink a big glass of water cuz
you're dehydrated in the morning and
then I wrote down my goals like here's
all I get done today my Wednesday goals
are this but you know if it's Thursday
my Thursday goals are this and then I
take a picture of it and I post it to my
social media to let people know like
accountability excuse what I'm doing
today and hopefully inspires other
people to do something similar when you
create a routine like that in the
morning not that works for me
maybe doesn't work for you maybe reading
the book doesn't work for you maybe
watching the video works for you
whatever that is when you can start your
day thinking about positive things being
around positive game-changing people who
make you want to level up when you then
can write down your goals in a positive
way and say I'm going to go out and
attack these things today and be excited
inspired by it it just makes such a
massive difference in your life if you
did that every day for a year again your
life would not be recognizable one year
from today because you've been taking
bold action and you believe in it every
single day we're again most people wake
up and they do the exact opposite you
hit the snooze button you let yourself
down again and you hit the snooze button
again you let yourself down again you
fought another day you're tired just
down some coffee you do nothing to make
you want to think bigger push outside
your comfort zone stretch a little bit
and you just now attack by the day you
open your phone there's emails and
things that you have to get to you're
constantly responding to other people's
requests for your time and your whole
thing falls apart so there's no wonder
that you just go when you want to eat
junk food and not
work out and think live socks like start
your day with intention every single
morning envision that positive future
for yourself and again whatever that
thing is in the morning that sets you up
for success there means the book it's
the water and writing down goals every
single day Saturday I do it Sunday I do
it every day this is a habit for success
to help get you from where you are to
where you want to be produce nice movies
in your mind and watch your life and
business dramatically change so the
question I think today is I'm curious
what is the movie that you need to
change in your mind what is that
negative repeating movie that keeps
coming up over and over and over again
in your head in your life that you need
to break free of and say no more
that dream is gone that movie is history
I'm making a new movie what is that
movie that negative one sharing the
comments below really excited to hear
from you
I also wanna give a quick shout out to
clothes clothes thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book here one
word it really really really means a lot
to me and I hope you enjoyed them so
thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you and I hope you continue
to believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot events best
I've been feeling a little bit
unmotivated and I've been feeling like I
should be doing something or I should be
just I feel like I should be pulled and
like it isn't I'm feeling uninspired
basically that's my question how do you
get when you lose inspiration and you
lose motivation how do you get it back I
get it back by remembering that you
might die tomorrow that's true
so I'm inspired by practicality and
reality and the truth which is it is
ridiculously impossible to become a
human being I am one I have other good
things going for me as a human being and
I'm just grateful you your dwelling and
looking at what you don't have versus
looking at what you have if you actually
looked at what you had your health you
know living in America you know who the
heck knows what would be on your list if
you actually spent all your time looking
at that versus I don't have a million
dollars I'm not famous I don't have this
if you spend all your time on what you
have versus what you don't have you
would be the happiest girl on earth if
you're convinced that you're going to
fail or fall or get hurt that will come
to fruition because that's what you're
visualizing I never vision you know I
was willing to get hurt along the way
but I didn't visualize myself getting
hurt along the way and I think that's
what that's what stops a lot of people
and that's really what separates a lot
of people from from being world
champions or from being as good as they
can because they they stop at some point
saying oh no I I am not capable of this
or I'll probably get hurt doing this and
if you approach anything with that
hesitation you're gonna fail I always
approached it like this is going to work
I'm going to figure this out even if it
takes me hundreds of attempts and I
wasn't you know the idea of falling
getting back up again that didn't really
bother me at all once I got started with
two magicians and one ventriloquist
helped me
once I got the knack of it it became
easier and then I joined and then would
make moments you know when I was
learning the script and I thought well
this isn't gonna work I mean how how can
I do it but I used to write notes to
myself little letters to myself and put
them on the desk saying you know it you
could do anything you know anything with
faith you can move mountains and trust
and let go and all that something you
know and I still just throw myself into
then and then the when the negatives
came to my mind there with the positive
positive sounds in my head you know make
I'd say I can do it you and I I used to
meditate and visualize myself doing it
nice to visualize myself on like a kind
of try and visualize myself doing those
sort of signing cards and spinning them
and and gradually surprising the power
of mind what happens you know your
muscles begin to respond it's like
anything that if you thing the piano or
driving a car comes through the
relaxation raise your standard Apple at
the core its core value is that we
believe that people with passion and not
one drop of myself work depends on your
it's something to me
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten roses success I have a
very special secret video for you these
are the individual clips that I have
personally learned the most from and
applied to my life and my business check
the link in description for details